quinze mille morts dans le monde nouveau
décompte à la mi-journée
si l'activité reprend progressivement en
chine à wuhan plus précisément le japon
de son côté craint pour ses jeux
olympiques un record du plus grand
événement sportif planétaire est de plus
en plus envisagée quentin mauclair
prévue du 24 juillet au 9 août prochain
les jeux olympiques de tokyo se dirige
doucement vers un possible report en
raison de la pandémie due coronavirus
prônant la patience lors des dernières
semaines
tokyo évoquent l'hypothèse pour la
première fois ses décisions du cio vont
dans le sens de la politique que j'ai
mentionnés à savoir l'organisation des
jeux olympiques dans leur intégralité
si cela devenait difficile en tenant
compte en priorité des assiettes
il pourrait devenir inévitable que nous
décidions de reporter les jo
la gouverneur de la capitale japonaise a
quant elle rappelé que la priorité
serait mis sur la santé
elle travaille chez nokia au tai-chi
match des oiseaux en tant que
représentante de la ville organisatrice
j'ai toujours expliqué qu'une annulation
des jeux était impensable mais aussi que
la priorité était des mesures contre le
coronavirus afin de protéger la santé et
la sécurité des citoyens de tokyo depuis
quelques jours les fédérations multiplie
les déclarations allant vers un report
de l'événement dans une lettre dévoilée
ce lundi c'est la fédération
internationale d'athlétisme qui a
demandé à ce que les géo et lieu
ultérieurement
après la déclaration de shinzo abe le
comité olympique australien a déclaré
que ces athlètes devraient privilégier
leur santé et se préparer pour 2021
même son de cloche pour le canada qui
n'enverra aucun la tête à tokyo cet été
le comité olympique canadien et le
comité paralympique canadien
appuyés par leur commission des athlètes
leurs organismes nationaux de sport et
par le gouvernement du canada ont pris
la décision difficile de ne pas envoyer
des équipes canadiennes aux jeux
olympiques et paralympiques au cours de
l'été 2020
le report des jeux olympiques est
également demandée par les fédération
française de natation et de judo de son
côté le président du comité national
olympique et sportif français denis
masseglia estime que le report des jo
est inévitable à partir du moment où le
cio indique qu'il réfléchit à d'autres
solutions c'est qu'il a déjà pris
l'option de les reporter
le cio a été pas mal critiquée alors
qu'il n'a jamais dit qu'il voulait
maintenir les jeux coûte que coûte
il a simplement dit qu'il était trop tôt
pour prendre une décision
je pense que le report est inévitable
2020-2021 ou 2022 le comité
international olympique se donne
désormais quatre semaines pour prendre
une décision à propos du sort des jeux
olympiques de tokyo